THANK YOU.
GOOD TRANSITION THERE.
JESSE.
POLITICS IS A GAME THAT TURNS
PLAYERS INTO MONSTERS AND
MONSTERS INTO PLAYERS.
WHEN DIANE FEINSTEIN GOT DR.
FORD'S ALLEGATION SHE WAS A
PLAYER.
RATHER THAN HOLD A PRIVATE
MEETING TO PROTECT THE FAMILIES
AND LIVES OF KAVANAUGH AND FORD
FEINSTEIN SAT ON IT UNTIL IT
COULD ONLY BECOME A SHOW TRIAL.
IT NORMALIZED COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
YOU DROP A BOMB AND INNOCENT
PEOPLE DIE.
THE MOB IN THAT ROOM KNEW THEIR
BOMB WOULD DESTROY REPUTATIONS
AND SCAR TWO KIDS.
THEY DID THE MATH.
THEY RELEASED THE PUBLIC
ACCUSATIONS LEAKING TWO
ACCOMPLICES.
IN THE END THE FORD LETTER WENT
FROM FEINSTEIN TO THE MEDIA.
FEINSTEIN DOESN'T KNOW HOW THIS
HAPPENED.
HOW COULD IT?
>> YOU TELL US YOUR STAFF DID
NOT LEAK IT?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE MY STAFF
WOULD LEAK IT.
I HAVE NOT ASKED THAT QUESTION
DIRECTLY.
>> DO YOU KNOW THAT?
HOW IN THE WORLD DID THAT GET IN
THE HAND OF THE PRESS?
>> THE ANSWER IS NO.
THE STAFF --
>> HAVE YOU ASKED YOUR STAFF?
>> I JUST DID.
PARDON ME?
>> WELL, SOMEBODY LEAKED IT.
IF IT WASN'T YOU.
>> IT WAS NOT -- I DID NOT.
>> OH, THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
CALL IS A MYSTERY.
FOR SURE IT WAS A MIRACLE ONE
THAT CREATED A HELL NO ONE WOULD
WANT TO ENDURE.
HAPPILY FOR FEINSTEIN AND
FRIENDS THE TARGET STILL ENTERED
THE COLISEUM.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN HE SAID, SHE
SAID.
THIS WE SAID.
DUE PROCESS REPLACED BY
VIGILANTES.
YESTERDAY WE SAW A MOB SPEAKING
PAYBACK.
A FEMALE VICTIM GETS USED.
A WIFE, MOTHER AND DAUGHTER ARE
WOUNDED.
AMERICA GETS SICK WHILE
FEINSTEIN HOLDS A PITCH FORK AND
SAYS WHO ME?
>> GOOD, GOOD.
>> THIS WAS SO MANUFACTURED.
WHERE MILLANO WAS SITTING OVER
KAVANAUGH'S SHOULDER.
SHE WAS THE GUEST OF FEINSTEIN
AND SMILING AND TEXTING.
IT WAS LIKE WHY WAS SHE THERE.
THAT WAS ORCHESTRATED.
THIS WAS A SHOW TRIAL.
>> THAT HAD THE INTENDED EFFECT.
LOOK WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WHEN KAVANAUGH CAME BACK,
SOMEONE TALKED TO HIM AT LUNCH
TIME AND SAID LISTEN, DUDE, YOU
WANT THIS JOB, YOU GET OUT AND
FIGHT FOR THIS JOB.
HE WENT BACK OUT THERE AND SWUNG
AND DID IT.
HE THE MOMENTUM.
GOT BACK ON TOP.
CRUISING TOWARDS THE NOMINATION
AND THEN JEFF FLAKE HAPPENED.
>> YES.
>> ANYONE AS A FORMER ACTIVIST
AND ATTORNEY MYSELF, IF YOU
THINK THOSE NOISY DEMONSTRATORS
HAVE NO IMPACT, TALK TO THE TWO
LADIES WHO CONFRONTED JEFF FLAKE
IN THAT ELEVATOR.
THEY MADE HISTORY.
HE DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE
STRONGEST ROD IN THE SHED
ANYWAY.
HE COLLAPSED.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THEY HAD NO CHOICE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID IT DIDN'T
COME FROM FLAKE.
IT CAME FROM FEINSTEIN.
>> THIS LETTER WENT TO THE
CONGRESSWOMAN, THE DEMOCRATS AND
FEINSTEIN.
THE ONLY THREE PEOPLE WHO HAD
CUSTODY.
FORD WAS COMPELLING AND
BELIEVABLE.
BUT SHE IS NAIVE.
AN ACADEMIC.
SHE SEEMED OUT OF IT AT TIMES.
SHE'S BEEN MANIPULATED BY THE
SEASON DEMOCRATS AND THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND BY HER
LAWYERS.
THE PROSECUTOR DID AN EXCELLENT
JOB EXPLAINING THAT.
HERE'S HOW:
THE WHOLE AFRAID OF FLYING.
THAT WAS MANUFACTURED.
SHE GOES TO HAWAII AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
SHE HAD JUST FLOWN BACK AND
FORTH ACROSS THE EAST COAST AND
WEST COAST.
THAT WAS A LIE.
SHE NEVER HEARD THE INVITATION
TO INTERVIEW HER.
HER LAWYERS KEPT THAT FROM HER.
>> SHOULDN'T THE LAWYERS BE IN
TROUBLE?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOUR
CLIENT EVERYTHING.
SHE HAD NO IDEA THAT OFFER WAS
PROFFERED.
THE POLYGRAPH WAS BIZARRE.
THEY DID ON THE SAME DAY SHE
WENT TO HER MOTHER'S FUNERAL.
THEY DIDN'T RELEASE THE AUDIO
AND VIDEO FROM THE POLYGRAPH.
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT PROSECUTOR
SAID THIS IS NOT HOW YOU TREAT A
TRUE VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
YOU DON'T POLYGRAH HER UP AND
PARADE HER OUT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
THESE PEOPLE LIKE WATCHING FORD
BEING TORTURED AND KAVANAUGH
BEING TORTURED.
IT WAS SADISTIC.
>> AND IT WAS ALSO PREMEDITATED.
THE DEMOCRATS I COME BACK TO
THIS POINT.
THE DEMOCRATS REPRESENT THE
PRO-CHOICE FORCES IN IN COUNTRY.
THEY HELD THE WEAK HAND.
THE PRO-LIFE FORCES OF THE
REPUBLICANS HOLDING THE STRONGER
HAND.
THE DEMOCRATS GET THE GOLDEN
TICKET IN THE FORM OF DR. FORD
ACCUSATIONS.
HOW WILL WE USE THIS?
WE WILL HOLD IT AND LOOK LIKE WE
ARE LOSING.
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
>> WHEN THIS FIRST CAME UP, NO,
WE ARE HOLDING A VOTE ON MONDAY
AND NOT PLAYING GAMES.
IF HE HAD DONE THAT, IT WOULD
HAVE AVOIDED THIS DELAY.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE JEOPARDIZED
THIS VOTE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> DO YOU THINK HE WOULD HAVE
SUFFERED?
>> HE WOULD HAVE SUFFERED.
>> REPUBLICANS IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY ARE NOT WILLING TO HEAR
FROM WOMEN ABOUT SECRETARY OF
STATE.
THE PLAYBOOK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN USING FOR DECADES.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A GOOD
LOOK.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE HERE WE ARE
TODAY.
>> ONE THING ABOUT DIANE
FEINSTEIN DROPPING THIS BOMB IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE COMMITTEE, HER
STAFF AND SENATOR GRASSLEY'S
STAFF, THEY USED TO HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
THEY HAD A PROFILE WORKING
>> NOT ON ABORTION.
>> LIKE PROTESTING WHISTLE
BLOWERS AND OVERSIGHT OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
SHE HAS DESTROYEDED ANY KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP THEY HAD IN THE
PAST AS THE LEFT CONTINUES TO
LECTURE THE RIGHT ABOUT COMING
TOGETHER AND WASHINGTON WORKING
TO BETTER THE COUNTRY.
SHE DESTROYED THAT RELATIONSHIP.
IT WAS A GOOD ONE.
SHE HAS A LOT OF EXPLAINING TO
DO.
THERE SHOULD BE AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> SHE IS TROUBLE WITH THE LEFT
IN CALIFORNIA?
>> MAYBE.
>> THIS IS BIG.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO THIS.
I WAS A YOUNG LAWYER WHEN ROE V.
WADE WAS ARGUED AND PASSED.
IT WAS A SEA CHANGE.
THIS WAS PROFOUND -- THE WOMEN
IN THE STREETS.
THE WOMEN'S MOVEMENT UNFOLDING.
THIS IS THE GENERATION LATER.
THE PRO-LIFE FORCE HIS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SWAY THINGS BACK
THEIR WAY.
A GENERATION LATER.
THIS IS THE FIGHT TO THE FINISH.
THIS IS ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
>> YOU CAN SAY THIS IS
POLITICAL.
THIS IS ABOUT ABORTION.
YOU CAN'T JUST KEEP CALLING FOR
INVESTIGATIONS OF UNCORROBORATED
CLAIMS.
THIS IS POLITICAL AND KAVANAUGH
SAID IT WAS POLITICAL WHICH THEY
HATE HIM FOR.
>> RIGHT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> THEY PLAYED DIRTY WITH
GARLAND.
>> NOT LIKE THIS.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU COULD
PREDICT OR SAY THAT WITH THIS
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION
ANYTHING HAPPENS TO ROE V. WADE.
I THINK THAT'S A GAME IN ITSELF.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S UNDER
THREAT.
>> I DO.
ROE V. WADE SAID THERE IS A
COMPETING INTEREST.
MOTHER AND UNBORN CHILD.
THE CHILD BECOMES VIABLE.
THE CHILD HAS THE RIGHTS OF A
HUMAN.
THAT DATE KEEPS GETTING PUSHED
BACK.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].